♪♪
-Let's get to the news.
Former President Trump
over the weekend
kicked off his 2024 campaign,
Merrick.
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump kicked
off his 2024 campaign
on Saturday at the New Hampshire
Republican Party's
annual meeting
and said, "I'm more angry now,
and I'm more committed now than
I ever was."
Though it's never a good sign
when your opening pitch is,
I'm blind with rage.
[ Laughter ]
While speaking on Saturday
in New Hampshire,
former President Trump said the
Taliban were incapable
of fighting at night because
they don't have binoculars.
I'm --
[ Laughter ]
I'm sorry.
Do you think binoculars
help you see at night?
[ Laughter ]
"Officer, I know you
pulled me over for not
having my headlights on.
But don't worry,
I got my binoculars."
[ Laughter ]
"Now I know what
you're thinking.
I can't hold the steering wheel
when I'm holding my binoculars."
"For that, you can write me
a ticket."
President Biden,
and Vice President
Kamala Harris are set to travel
to Philadelphia on
Friday for the DNC's
winter convention.
For those who don't know
what that is,
winter used to be a season where
it was really cold outside.
[ Laughter ]
Florida Congressman Matt Gaetz
discussed his role
in the contentious speakership
election in a new interview
and said he's "not some
'Lord of the Flies' nihilist."
"We're reading that in class,"
said his girlfriend.
[ Laughter ]
[ Audience oohs ]
It's a good book.
New York Mayor -- New York Mayor
Eric Adams told reporters
last week that he thinks
Republican Congressman
George Santos should resign.
While Santos disagreed and said
he's actually
the Mayor of New York City.
[ Laughter ]
A 29-year-old recently
attempted to enroll
at a high school in New Jersey,
which I think was the plot
of "Grease?"
[ Laughter ]
That's right, a 29-year-old
woman was charged last week
with providing a false
government document
after she allegedly provided
a fake birth certificate
and tried to enroll
at a New Jersey high school.
Teachers knew something was off
after it seemed like
she wanted to be there.
[ Laughter ]
The San Antonio Zoo is offering
a Valentine's Day promotion
to name a cockroach after
customers' exes for $10.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, they'll do it
for 5 bucks at Arby's.
[ Laughter ]
[ Audience oohs ]
"Yeah, just take your pick."
[ Laughter ]
And finally, authorities in
Australia have recently begun
searching for a missing
radioactive capsule.
And they think
they just found it.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ]
President Biden
informed Congress yesterday
that he will officially end
the coronavirus pandemic
emergency declaration in May,
which means that everyone
can finally
stop wearing their mask
a year ago.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden visited
New York City today
and spoke about how the
bipartisan infrastructure law
will improve
the Hudson River Tunnel
that connects
New York and New Jersey.
The biggest improvement --
it will no longer connect
to New Jersey.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
The Biden administration
unveiled a proposal yesterday
that would make birth control
more easily accessible.
That's great.
Now can you do razors?
[ Laughter ]
President Biden
confirmed last week
that White House chief of staff
Ron Klain
will step down in
the coming weeks and said,
"The real mark of Ron's success
is that he's beloved
by the team he leads."
Though I'd say
the real mark of Ron's success
is that this is the first
we're all hearing of him.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden is set to travel
to Philadelphia this week
to discuss
an infrastructure project
that will replace lead pipes.
But then how are Philadelphians
supposed to collect their debts?
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
people don't want their partners
to earn
less than $30,000 a year.
This news first reported
by a guidance counselor
to a philosophy major.
[ Laughter ]
"But, like, can you even
name one who's working today?"
After vacationing
for the last month in Orlando,
former Brazilian president
Jair Bolsonaro
has reportedly applied
for a six-month visitor visa.
I'm sorry.
You saw Orlando
and wanted to stay longer?
[ Laughter ]
"An IHOP and an Applebee's!
Call the consulate
and tell them I'm not leaving!"
[ Laughter ]
The U.K. announced plans today
to improve its environment
and hopes to restore
at least 1.2 million acres
of wildlife habitat
to protect rare species
like hedgehogs
and red squirrels.
Because if those die out,
it could mean the end of the
traditional English breakfast.
[ Audience groans ]
[ Laughter ]
[British accent] "The best we
can do is Impossible hedgehog."
[ Laughter ]
Florida law-- [ Laughs ]
Florida lawmakers
proposed legislation yesterday
that would allow residents to
carry firearms without a permit.
I don't know.
I guess they figure
it can't be any more dangerous
than letting
100-year-olds drive.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
according to a new study,
kids missed about 35%
of a normal year's worth
of learning during
the coronavirus pandemic.
Said kids, "Oh, my God!
That's more than half a year!"
President Biden is said to have
his annual physical
later this month.
Well, at least that's one probe
that won't turn up
any documents.
[ Laughter ]
God willing.
The FBI reportedly searched
President Biden's
Delaware beach house today
as part of the ongoing
investigation
into his handling
of classified documents.
And I think he might
be getting nervous,
because he said, "You know what
you should be searching?
Hunter's laptop.
Crazy stuff in there."
[ Laughter ]
Democratic Congressman
Jamie Raskin asked
the Secret Service yesterday
to turn over visitor logs
to Mar-a-Lago and former
Vice President Mike Pence's
Indiana home.
Let me save you the time --
Domino's guy and no one.
[ Laughter ]
The Biden administration
proposed new rules today
that would limit
credit card company fees
for missed payments.
"Oh, I never charge anything,"
said Merrick Garland.
[ Laughter ]
[ Audience murmurs ]
[ Groans ]
According to a new poll,
15% of voters said
that the most important problem
facing the county's inflation --
oh, wait, now it's 20%?
Oh, God, now it's 25-- 30%?
Oh, my God, you know what?
I'm gonna stop looking.
I'm gonna just stop looking.
Authorities in Texas
yesterday located
the two emperor tamarin monkeys
that went from the Dallas Zoo
inside the closet
of an abandoned home.
And they left them there because
at this point,
that's a more secure location
than the Dallas Zoo.
[ Laughter ]
Tomorrow is groundhog day,
which is weird,
'cause we still haven't had
the first six weeks of winter.
[ Laughter ]
According to new analysis,
the price of beef is expected
to increase this year by 15%,
so it's gonna be weird
when the price
of a Quarter Pounder doesn't.
[ Laughter ]
Then what is it?
And finally, the candy executive
who's credited
as the father of Peeps, for
creating the marshmallow treat,
died recently at the age of 98.
And his last words were, "Please
don't let them call me
the father of Peeps."
[ Laughter ]
According to a new poll,
President Biden's
approval rating has risen
1 point over the last month.
So now he's going to keep
discovering more and more
classified documents
until he clinches re-election.
The FBI searched
President Biden's Delaware
beach house yesterday
and reported
that they did not
find any classified documents.
Of course not.
You think that's what Joe Biden
reads at the beach?
It's Tom Clancy
or nothing down there.
After facing criticism from
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis,
the College Board yesterday
released a revised framework
for its new A.P.
African-American Studies course,
which no longer
features sections on
reparations, prison abolition,
and black queer studies.
Instead, students will just
watch "Friends."
At a House Judiciary Committee
meeting yesterday,
Florida Congressman
Matt Gaetz proposed
that every meeting begin with
the pledge of allegiance,
just like they do
at his girlfriend's school.
The New York groundhog
Staten Island Chuck
did not see his shadow today.
Said residents,
"Yeah, you didn't see nothin'."
During this year's annual
Groundhog Day celebration,
Punxsutawney Phil predicted
another six weeks of winter.
Okay, but did he
see his shadow or a calendar?
Of course winter's not over.
It's February 2nd.
There's still football.
Can we at least move
the stupid ritual
to mid-March,
where there's a little mystery?
The Federal Reserve raised
interest rates yesterday
by a quarter point,
which is going to make it
even harder to get approved
for a loan to buy eggs.
The fast-food chain Subway
has announced
that it will begin slicing meat
in-store in front of customers.
And it can't be a good sign
when your customers' reaction
to your sandwiches is,
"Prove it."
"I'll wait."
Amid reports that the retailer
will file for bankruptcy,
Bed Bath & Beyond
announced yesterday
it will close 87 stores
across the country.
But, remember,
every time God closes a door,
he opens a Spirit Halloween.
And, finally,
a 6-year-old in Michigan
recently ordered
about $1,000 worth of food
on a delivery app while
playing with his father's phone.
Even more impressive,
his wife bought that story.
"I mean, I feel like I should
eat it since it's here."
That was the monologue,
everybody!